so I preempted my own question we have
so far to see and looked at the service
area of prisms after prisms we looked at
round things what are they called again
the cylinders very good and when movies
forward into pyramids together now put
your hand up if when you looked at this
shape you easily knew sorry it still he
knew that there were 14 faces today I
look at it straight away I can not deny
when I had to check this answer for
myself I sort of redrew her a little bit
there all these signs at the back that
you can't see and that's just quite
dangerous because it's easy to miss
count okay it's the same thing for all
3d shapes which is why just like weight
the cylinder I thought it would be handy
if you could actually see a pyramid
now it's not a beautiful pyramid I
apologize but it does the job now do you
remember when we were looking before at
prisons like say a prison like this
we name these not just prisons but it's
a specific kind of prison what kind is
it
have a look carefully now there is a
rectangle key art if you work out the
surface area you're gonna have to
include actually gonna have to have
three rectangles we don't call it a
rectangular prison that what is it it's
a triangular prism and it's named that
because because of what it's the
cross-section very good and you can see
it all the way through right if you have
a loaf of bread that we check every
slice is going to Train prisms and
they're not big cross-sections but
pyramids are named after their basements
okay so I want you to look again at my
pyramid I know it's a bit small I wanted
a bigger but who's the paper that I had
what kind of a pyramid is this this
particular one is a rectangular prism
okay you can try a pyramid keep saying
that you can have square periods you can
have triangular periods any different
kind of base that you like so we're
gonna work out the surface area of this
thing the question is how many sides
does this and we'll do this as an
example how many sides does this
rectangular pyramid how many faces as
you take how many does it have has five
faces right now again think about it and
you may like to draw your own little
rectangular pyramid for yourself in your
book so you can see what's going on you
can see it's a rectangular pyramid so
one of the faces is a rectangle
now you've then got four more phases
since you said there's a total of five
I want you have a look at them you see
them you can see them on your diagram as
well all four of the remaining phases
are they all the same
so they are all triangular but in this
case because the base you can see it's
got different leaves up and down
so therefore the triangles that come
from those sides are going to be
different does that make sense
I do have pears though so I'm gonna say
two fingers just like before when we did
the cylinder I'd like you to draw not
just your pyramid but also a net of your
pyramid and just like before I'm gonna
take the scissors to it so you can see
what's going on and I'd love to have
yours again I'm gonna say this a lot
throughout the year and move on to the
last side if you've got colors they are
useful because a problem well seen is a
problem solved so if you can look at it
more clearly and understand it in colors
will help you with that
unless it was one then you will
understand it much more easily okay so
you can see I am color coding my faces
here you can see I've got sugar green
triangles two blue triangles and there's
my red over there
so wherever you work out the surface
area of a pyramid you have to make sure
these all come along for the ride